A few nights passed and only half of the moon was left.
The animals feared the moon would soon disappear.
After a week their fears came true.
The moon disappeared.
They all ran to wise old Owl to tell him that the moon had disappeared.
"You're all very silly,"...
...said Owl.
"Gather around and I will teach you a lesson about the moon."
"There are two things you need to know about the moon,"...
...said Owl.
"First, the moon does not shine on its own.
The sun lights up the moon.
Second, the moon does not sit still in the sky.
It moves around Earth."
"Oh, yes,"...
...said Owl.
"There is one more thing you need to know.
The moon is like a ball."
"The sun can only light up one side of the moon
So when the moon moves around Earth, you see only the part of the side that the sun lights up."
Owl went on to say that sometimes you only see half of the lighted side.
"This is called a half moon,"...
...he said.
"At other times you see all of the lighted side.
This is called a full moon."
"And sometimes you do not see the lighted side at all.
You see the dark side.
This is called the new moon."
"But don't worry.
The moon did not disappear,"...
...said Owl.
"Soon after a new moon, you will see a small part of the lighted side come back."
The other animals began to feel better after listening to Owl talk.
A few nights after Owl's lesson, the animals were out playing.
Squirrel looked up and saw a small sliver of the moon.
"Owl was right,"...
...Squirrel yelled.
"The moon is coming back!"
The moon grew bigger each night.
Soon there was a full moon again.
The animals had a full moon party!